c'est le tapis rouge de l'année ans
la grande première du méga production
longuement entendue sauf tchernobyl
l'oeuvre de la coqueluche du cinéma ici
des lilas cause l'ex nous a parlé juste
avant la projection du film qu'il a
réalisé avec l'aide de nul autre que l'
agence de l'énergie atomique de la
russie qui était autrefois responsable
de la centrale de tchernobyl nous dire
qu'elle raconte l'histoire d'un jeune
pompier à l'excès se porte volontaire
avec trois autres hommes pour aller vite
des réservoirs du réacteur en feu
contrairement à la série anglaise tous
les personnages tant fait le film se
veut un hommage à ce qu on a baptisé les
liquidateurs six cent mille hommes et
femmes appelées vous voyez le pire
accident nucléaire de l'histoire
des monuments vivant qui auront attendu
trente cinq ans pour que le cinéma russe
aborde enfin la catastrophe
mais quelle déception du général nicolaï
tarakan à cahors en 1986 c'est lui qui
était le grand responsable de
l'opération nettoyage des déchets
radioactifs du réacteur le rôle du
général tarakan hommes étaient à ce
point crucial qu'il fait partie de la
série des et du bio il faut que le choix
il avait sous sa commande milite jeune
soldat qui n'avait aucune espèce d'idée
du danger qui les attendaient sur place
ah ça c'est nicolas ici en juin 1986 il
prépare ses soldats et les habits les
envoie sur le toit du réacteur nucléaire
pour nettoyer tout ce qui restait de
débris radioactifs tels attache
probablement une des tâches les plus
dangereuses allait donc bien sûr sur la
ste marie rausch tout cas excellent date
à part cela dit c'était tout au plus
c'est bon signe
[Musique]
dans les villes nucléaires de russie où
il ya encore des centrales et d'où
étaient originaires la majorité de ces
bénévoles soldats et civils
le souvenir est aussi douloureux nous
sommes associés biborg devant le
monument érigé en l'honneur des 1400
volontaires qui comme romane canio sont
partis en catastrophe en 1986
bien essayé mais tac toe yes it chaska
d'ataka ebitda nous avons pu rencontrer
ces liquidateurs quelques jours avant la
première
alors quel film tchernobyl leur était
présenté par le réalisateur et nous
avons constaté en personne les critiques
qui les suit pour un ouvrage qui selon
eux n'est pas la hauteur de leurs
sacrifices et lilou des deux allait
gagner c'est ouégnin dans la salle le
malaise est palpable et en dit long
surtout pas sur le film mais sur les
frustrations de ces héros oubliés dont
peu de gens connaissent les séquelles
des cancers au traumatisme psychologique
et la plupart de ces liquidateurs ont en
commun le sentiment d'avoir été
abandonné par l'état d'abord qu'il leur
verse plus les compensations d'autres
fonds général tarakan of dit qu'il a
encore des cauchemars et dans les
circonstances s'attendaient à beaucoup
mieux d'un film fait par les plus
talentueux du cinéma
mais la pire catastrophe nucléaire de
l'humanité en divertissement est un
exercice périlleux
même si c'est un devoir de mémoire pour
le liquidateur de la dîmière grigoriev
ce film tant attendu n'est ni un chef
d'oeuvre ni une gifle mais la preuve que
la russie est incapable de parler de
tchernobyl à juste titre un désastre
monumental 35 ans plus tard dit il
l'industrie nucléaire est toujours dans
le déni des risques qu'elles posent et
pas seulement russie